there have been long debates and many
disagreements among historians and
political scientists and other scholars
about who was the most significant
figure in the history of our
civilization
in my mind there really is no question
how can anyone even compare with the man
jesus for historical significance
not only has the church founded in his
name been the most powerful religious
political social and cultural force in
the history of the west for the past
1600 years
but today
over 2 billion people worship him
and claim they try to follow his
teachings
about how many other figures in history
can that be said
and millions of other people try to
emulate his teachings without personally
believing in him
no one in history can approach this
level of influence
but is it jesus himself who has been
important
or is it the later beliefs about him
that have transformed the world
even if it's true that christianity has
affected the course of human
civilization
did the man jesus himself
another way of putting this question is
this was jesus himself the first
christian
the one who started christianity
on one level the answer may seem
obviously yes
jesus was the founder of the christian
movement
but as we'll see
in a very important sense the answer is
just as obviously no
the religion founded on jesus
was arguably very different in
significant ways from what jesus himself
believed taught and stood for
for some listeners that will be a highly
controversial statement
for others it'll be simple common sense
however one personally comes down on
this question
it's important to begin any discussion
of the christianization of the roman
empire by exploring what we can know
about the life and teachings of the man
himself
jesus of nazareth
most readers of the bible may not
realize this but understanding the life
and teachings of jesus is a very large
and extraordinarily complicated endeavor
the good news for listeners is that
there's an entire 24 lecture great
courses course on the historical jesus
devoted entirely to the topic
but in some ways even that course
provides just a deep scratch into the
surface
in this lecture i'll be able only to
summarize the most important points by
asking three sets of questions
first
what are our ancient sources of
information for knowing what jesus did
and said and how reliable are these
sources
second
how do scholars utilize these sources
for historical information
third
what are the results of that kind of
study that is what can we say about the
life and teachings of jesus
as with the study of any historical
figure we obviously have to begin with
our sources themselves
in terms of basic chronology
jesus public ministry occurred sometime
in the late 20s of the 1st century ce
he was executed around the year 30.
it is interesting and surprising to note
that jesus is never mentioned by any
non-christian non-jewish source of the
entire first christian century
we have lots of sources written by greek
and roman authors
we have histories we've got biographies
we've got a literature of all kinds we
have personal letters that people sent
back and forth we have inscriptions on
buildings and jesus is never mentioned
in any of those writings
that shouldn't be surprising however
because 99.99
of people
also are not mentioned
all people never mentioned
but if you want to know what jesus said
and did you can't turn to other writings
because they don't exist
he is mentioned very briefly in just a
few sentences
by one jewish source of the first
century the historian josephus whom
we've already mentioned
josephus tells us almost nothing about
what jesus actually said and did but he
does have a few sentences devoted to the
major points of jesus life
we do have later accounts of jesus from
non-canonical gospels
gospel accounts of what jesus said and
did that did not make it into the new
testament everyone agrees though that
these are almost entirely later and
highly legendary
and so our best sources of information
are the four accounts of jesus life in
the new testament the gospels of matthew
mark luke and john
i should say that the other books of the
new testament the other 23 books say
almost nothing about jesus actual life
about what was happening between the
time he was born and the time he died
but we do have the four gospels
most casual readers of the bible and
probably most non-readers of the bible
simply assume that these books the four
gospels present straightforward
biographical accounts of jesus life
if marx says jesus did something it's
something he really did
if john's gospel reports a speech of
jesus jesus spoke those words just as
they are reported
that's the common view
since the development of modern methods
of historical scholarship however
especially in the 19th century and going
on until today
scholars have realized that it's not
that simple
as we're going to see
we can't simply quote a verse from one
of the gospels and assume it's relating
history as it really happened
any more than we can do so with an
account of any other ancient figure
whether we're talking about moses
or socrates or the prophet muhammad
the reason is because these sources do
not provide transcripts
of what jesus or any of the others
actually said
based on stenographic notes taken at the
time
nor do they give us accounts of his
actions based on video recordings
i can't go into all the details here
but i do need to stress that the gospels
we have are all written
anonymously
we call them matthew mark luke and john
those were the later names associated
with them but the authors don't give us
their names or indicate that they were
followers of jesus or disciples or
disciples of the disciples
we do know that they were written by
greek speaking christians
who were living 40 to 60 years
after the death of jesus
and they were reporting what they had
heard from storytellers about the things
jesus said and did if jesus died in the
year 30 and we have very good reasons
for thinking that these gospels were
written 40 to 60 years later
the only way they could have gotten
their stories were by stories that had
been circulating by word of mouth
for decades
before the accounts were written down
you probably know what happens to oral
traditions that are in circulation just
for a day or two a week or two
these have been in circulation for years
many people assume that in ancient
cultures they preserved oral cultures
oral traditions accurately and didn't
change them well
scholars have shown in fact that's
that's actually not true
it's clear that these accounts were
changed over the years
from one storyteller to the next
one way for knowing that is the gospels
themselves have numerous differences
in telling the same stories and
sometimes these differences are actual
discrepancies in what they report
i'm not going to be giving you details
here we could spend an entire course on
that but you can see for yourself what i
mean
all you need to do is take two or more
accounts of the same story in any of the
gospels
it could be the story of jesus birth
in matthew and luke the account of his
death and any of the gospels the account
of his resurrection and make a very
detailed comparison
this is uh you you read one of the
accounts and you take scrupulous notes
and this is what this one says this is
what matthew says about it then same
thing mark and then luke and then john
and compare your notes just do it
yourself
you'll find the differences and if you
look closely
many of these differences cannot be
reconciled
that shows that people are changing the
stories
and that's the problem with simply
quoting a verse here or there
to prove what jesus actually did or said
different gospel sources report
different things
that's not a problem per se but
sometimes the differences are actual
contradictions
how do scholars utilize sources of that
kind
sources that are written long after the
fact
based on traditions that had been
circulating orally
historians of course have to deal with
this kind of problem
all the time not just historians of the
new testament but also scholars of 5th
century bce athens
or 1st century rome or 6th century
byzantium or 18th century america
this is what scholars have to deal with
scholars of the gospels apply some
rather commonsensical rules to figure
out what in our sources for jesus life
probably goes back to what actually
happened
and what represents some kind of
distortion
or even invention in the historical
record
and so let me let me tell you some of
the some of the methods that historians
typically use
to begin with historians are almost
always interested in written records
that are closest
in time to the events they describe
the further removed they are from the
events that they narrate the more likely
they become changed because there's more
time for the changes to have been made
when it comes to the gospels that means
that john
our latest gospel probably written in
the 90s so over 60 years after jesus
death
john's gospel is generally seen as less
reliable on the whole than mark our
earliest gospel written 20 25 30 years
earlier
i'm not saying that john is therefore
thoroughly untrustworthy
and i'm not saying that mark is
therefore completely reliable
but all other things being equal
when you have discrepancies you're more
likely to find good historical
information in our earliest sources than
our latest sources
another criterion is that if you find a
story about jesus in just one of our
sources
it's almost impossible to know whether
this is a distortion
or an exaggeration or even a story that
that author simply made up if it's found
only one place
there's no way to uh to corroborate it
but if it's found in two or more
independent sources
which did not rely on each other for
their information then obviously neither
of them made it up
scholars then tried to figure out what
about these gospels can be independent
do matthew and
luke have a source other than mark for
example for their stories is john
dependent on matthew and mark and luke
or what kind of independent sources
where people were not relying on each
other and if you have stories that are
independently attested especially if
they're independently attested in lots
of sources and obviously those stories
are more likely to be things that
happened because no one of these sources
could have made it up since independent
sources know about it
moreover
another criterion if a story told by a
christian source promotes a particular
point of view
or a perspective
or a belief that the author himself
obviously held dear and wanted to
emphasize
it's hard to know if that author has
altered the historical record in order
to make it support his belief
but if you have a source that tells a
story that seems to run
counter
to what the author otherwise would like
to affirm and believe
well he obviously didn't make that one
up
he's not telling it because he's trying
to promote his own agenda
but simply because he heard it happened
if you have stories that cut across the
gospel's own agendas
and if you find these in multiple
independent sources there's a much
greater probability that these
particular stories are historical
what scholars do of course is they go
through the gospels story by story
sentence by sentence almost word by word
to decide
which ones are independently attested
and which ones are not promoting a
particular agenda that and and if you
can show that
then that story that word that sends is
more likely historically accurate
also and finally
if there's a story that does not make
any sense
in its alleged historical context
you know it can't be right
for example in modern times suppose
you're reading a story about a chef
in the 1920s
who's upset with her microwave
[Music]
you know this can't be a historical
story there were michael waves 1920
if there are stories about jesus that
make no sense from what we know about
first century israel for example from
the writings of josephus and other
sources if they really cannot be located
in the first century of israel they
almost certainly cannot be accepted as
reliable
those are the kind of criteria that
scholars use and the vast majority of
scholars using those criteria agree on
certain pieces of factual information
about jesus
these are some of the facts that i think
we know
jesus was born and raised in the jewish
household
and was thoroughly jewish in every way
from the beginning of his life to the
end
jesus was from a small hamlet
in northern israel called nazareth
we know about nazareth from archaeology
we don't know it from any literary
sources from the time it's never
mentioned in the old testament it's not
mentioned in josephus it's not mentioned
in jewish sources of the day because it
was so small and insignificant
but archaeologists have dug it up and
they've shown that in fact it was small
and insignificant
it was occupied entirely by lower class
farmers and day laborers who are living
a hand-to-mouth existence they've dug it
up
and
it maybe had 200 300 people living in it
it was not a significant place there
were no public buildings in it no
schools no synagogue nothing it's just a
group of houses a hamlet
we don't know anything for certain about
jesus upbringing
although there are obviously good
reasons for thinking he always was or at
least became
seriously committed to the religious
traditions of israel
jesus native language was aramaic
it's a language related to hebrew
it's debated whether jesus would have
known other languages
greek was the lingua franca of the
educated elite throughout the roman
empire but in small rural hamlets and
towns in galilee and other places
throughout the empire they didn't speak
greek
it's possible jesus spoke greek but
the evidence seems to be against it and
he almost certainly didn't know latin
he probably spoke arabic
jesus almost certainly worked impossibly
starting out as a boy
doing what his father did
which may have involved some kind of
carpentry work there's only one verse in
the new testament that says
jesus was a carpenter
mark chapter 6 verse 3
the greek word that's used there is tech
tone jesus was a tech tone
and a tech tone really means somebody
who works with their hands and so it
could be a stonesmith or a metalsmith or
somebody works with wood if he did work
with wood it wouldn't have been fine
cabinetry he would have been making
gates and yokes and other rough wood
products
as an adult jesus appears to have left
home to engage in an itinerant preaching
ministry
we don't know his age at the time
according to the gospel of luke he was
about 30
but i'm not sure how luke would know
this luke was writing 50 years later
the other gospels don't say how long did
his ministry last
well if you read the gospel mark it
seems like it lasts a few months
john indicates it must have lasted over
two years between two and three years
because he indicates jesus celebrated
three different passover festivals
so those are those are basic things we
know about jesus we also know the kind
of views that jesus brought to his
teaching
i've already said the jews at the time
had wide a wide range of beliefs and
practices
one of the dominant jewish belief
systems at the time
is a belief system that scholars call
apocalypticism it comes from the greek
word apocalypsis which means a
disclosing or a revealing
this was a widespread view
jewish apocalypticists who believed that
god had disclosed or revealed that the
end of history was coming had a certain
way of expressing their views
in their view the world that they live
in was controlled by forces of evil
why is this world such a mess if god has
controlled it if god created this if
god's in charge why is there so much
poverty and misery and suffering
well different people have different
answers the apocalyptis has said
that god had allowed the forces of evil
to take over
but
he is soon going to intervene in history
to destroy those forces of evil and
bring in a good kingdom here on earth
god would intervene
and he would annihilate the powers
aligned against him and everybody who
sided with them
but
those who are on the side of god
will be brought into a paradise
a return to the garden of eden
everyone who had been faithful to god
will return to the place that god had
originally designed for humans
this view as i said was supported by a
wide swath of jews in jesus time in the
jewish homeland including pharisees
and the members of the dead sea scroll
community the essenes john the baptist
the latter of whom
jesus associated with before beginning
his own ministry jesus starts out
associating with an apocalypticist john
the baptist
that is the first recorded event in
jesus life in the gospels the first
thing jesus does before his ministry is
he gets baptized by john the baptist
an apocalyptic preacher
urging jews to repent of their sins in
light of the judgment of god that was
soon to arrive
jesus aligned himself with john at the
outset of his ministry
that shows where jesus own ministry was
heading
he too was to proclaim the imminent
arrival of the kingdom of god and the
need to repent in preparation for it
jesus proclamation can be summarized in
his first recorded words our earliest
gospel was mark
and the first thing jesus says in mark
is found in mark chapter 1 verse 15
after jesus is baptized he goes through
his temptation and then he arrives
among his people and he proclaims
the time has been fulfilled
the kingdom of god
is at hand
repent
and believe the good news
this is an apocalyptic message
the time has been fulfilled as an
apocalyptic idea that the forces of evil
have a certain amount of time allotted
to them and the time is up
the kingdom of god
where there'll be a utopia on earth
which god will rule not these crummy
governments in charge now is at hand
it's near it's almost here
you need to get ready for it repent and
turn back to god
so that you will enter into god's
kingdom
jesus taught that a judgment day was
imminent
the kingdom of god for jesus was not
heaven when you die jesus did not think
that you died and your soul went to
heaven jesus like other jews in his time
thought that the kingdom of god was an
actual kingdom
here on earth
run by god through his messiah the
future leader of israel
jesus taught
that this kingdom of god would be
brought by a kind of heavenly cosmic
judge
who would come from heaven in order to
judge the earth
and he would rid this world of the evil
governments that are currently
running the world now
this cosmic judge is going to destroy
those governments
and the representatives who on their
representatives and everyone who sides
with them
only god's true followers would enter
into this coming kingdom
and jesus thought this utopian kingdom
was coming very soon
people need to prepare for it
how soon is it coming
jesus tells his disciples
some of you standing here will not taste
death before they see that the kingdom
of god has come in power
he's talking to his disciples you won't
some of you won't die before you see it
come
this generation
will not pass away before all these
things take place says jesus
people need to prepare
for this coming kingdom
by changing their ways and devoting
themselves to god and actively engaging
in helping those in need
those who do that
will be fulfilling god's law the torah
and those are the people that god will
enable to enter into his kingdom
at the end of his life jesus decided to
take his message to the capital of the
jewish homeland jerusalem itself
and its glorious temple where many
thousands of jews would be gathered
together
during one of the great jewish feasts
passover
an annual festival that celebrated god's
deliverance of his people israel from
their slavery in egypt many centuries
before as recounted in the book of
exodus
jesus made a journey with his disciples
to jerusalem
and while he was there he proclaimed his
message that there is a coming
destruction and people need to repent to
prepare for it so that they could enter
into the kingdom
this message included some inflammatory
ideas that would not have set well with
the ruling establishment
god was soon going to destroy his
enemies those who are now in power
including the roman overlords
and the priests who are running the
temple who cooperated with the roman
overlords
jesus appears to have acquired enough
listeners
to make those in power nervous
about a riot possibly breaking out over
his incendiary words
during this festival when jerusalem had
multiplied in size with all the pilgrims
and so the authorities had jesus
arrested
jesus appeared before the roman governor
pontius pilate
who was in the city precisely to control
the crowds pilate normally lived in
caesarea but for the passover feast he'd
come in because of the crowds
after a brief trial
on a charge of sedition against the
state
in which jesus was asked
are you the king of the jews
pilate decided to hand him over to be
crucified
jesus was declaring himself the king of
the coming kingdom
that would replace the kingdom of rome
this was a charge of sedition
jesus was immediately taken off to be
crucified
according to the earliest accounts
he was dead within six hours
in the ancient roman world there was no
such thing as due process
the roman governor pilate could decide
jesus fate on the spot
and he did so
jesus then was executed for believing
this apocalyptic message that the end
was coming soon the kingdom of god would
soon arrive
and he would be made the king
this way of looking at jesus life and
teaching may not be exactly what you've
heard before
but it's become a standard view among
scholars of the new testament since
albert schweitzer wrote his classic
study the quest of the historical jesus
well over a century ago where schweitzer
argued that jesus was in fact an
apocalypticist and that this was the
core of his message
in particular you may have noticed that
in this summary i've given i've not said
anything about jesus preaching of his
death and resurrection
that that is what bring would bring
about the salvation of the world
jesus death and resurrection of course
is the central teaching of christianity
it doesn't appear to be what jesus
himself preached
based on a critical study of our
earliest sources
that's why using the historical methods
i described earlier i asked was jesus a
christian
his message was apparently not that his
crucifixion would bring about the
salvation of the world the historical
jesus did not preach about a salvation
based on his death and resurrection he
preached about the need to repent and
return to keeping god's law and view of
the coming kingdom
as scholars of early christianity have
long said
christianity became the religion about
jesus rather than than the religion of
jesus
jesus own religion was the jewish view
that the god of israel was soon to
intervene in the world by sending a
cosmic savior from heaven to destroy the
forces of evil
and set up his kingdom on earth with
jesus himself at the head
after his death
his followers shifted the message
it was the death of jesus and his
resurrection that ultimately mattered
that brought salvation
how this shift actually happened is a
crucial factor in understanding how the
followers of jesus formed a religion
that could take over the
world that will be the subject of the
next lecture